why I think he's one of the more
brilliant and interesting figures of our
time I think also Steve Jobs isn't an
incredible weirdo I actually questioned
whether he is altogether sane he seems a
to be a person of I seems to be a kind
of a paranoid figure certainly a
mercurial figure the last person that
that that I or I can't imagine why
anyone would want to want to work for
this guy and the fact that that many
many people in the media business are
now counting on him to save them seems
dubious to me but having said all that I
would still stand by he is the most
interesting and among the most brilliant
figures to
I think he can save the the media
business because he thinks they they
think he has a magic machine they think
he is a magic touch and they think he is
a magic machine and and and and he has
he I think many people have come to
think of him as and he to some degree
represents himself as the odd the
alternative to the to the curse of
internet which has threatened to destroy
the media business